the lights are on
but most people will be at home during
the run-up to christmas
in large parts of england due to enter
tier 3
the toughest level of restrictions in
coventry this roof terrace bar was due
to open
next week now work has stopped and the
bookings all cancelled
we've decided to invest a further 40 000
pounds
to construct like a ski chalet type feel
as you can see we're very close to
getting that ready for an opening on the
4th of december
absolutely gutting restaurants in the
city are now closed for the foreseeable
future
people's lives and livelihoods on hold
the government has said all places that
have been put into tier 3 will be
supported with
mass testing and people will be offered
the kind of rapid tests that have been
available in liverpool
from next week local authorities will be
able to apply for support from nhs
test and trace and the armed forces but
the leader of coventry city council says
the details they've had so far
are limited we expect that we're going
to get around about 30 000 kids now
what i don't know is the the full extent
of what is being proposed
but i think it should be seen in
conjunction uh in respect to getting
test track and trace sorted out first
in manchester where they've faced extra
restrictions since
july a warning that some businesses
won't survive a winter in tier three
we are going to see mass closures and we
are going to see mass redundancies
let's not forget this at the moment in
the uk there's still two million people
in hospitality who are still furloughed
i think we're going to see a large
majority now made redundant
the tranquility of cornwall couldn't be
further from the doom and gloom
elsewhere
the only county on the mainland going
into tier 1
people will be able to taste freedom
again and mix
in groups of up to six we've lost 50
of our seating area anyway because of
social distancing we're only a small
cafe
so just being able to have that
flexibility of mixing
bubbles together and things and you know
it gives everyone all the locals the
option of meeting up with friends and
family in the cafe
the prime minister has warned losing
control of the virus over christmas
could force a return to national
lockdown
in the new year becky johnson sky news
coventry